D‘ANGELO ABOUT HER CHALLENGING NEW BOOK AND ITS IMPLICATIONS ROBYN. D‘ANGELO
NEW BOOK AND ITS IMPLICATIONS ROBYN. D‘ANGELO THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
ROBYN. D‘ANGELO THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME ON THE SHOW TONIGHT
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME ON THE SHOW TONIGHT YOUR BIG BESTSELLER WAS WHITE
ON THE SHOW TONIGHT YOUR BIG BESTSELLER WAS WHITE FRAGILITY. WHY IT‘S SO HARD
YOUR BIG BESTSELLER WAS WHITE FRAGILITY. WHY IT‘S SO HARD FOR WHITE PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT
FRAGILITY. WHY IT‘S SO HARD FOR WHITE PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT IS CALLED NICE RACISM.
FOR WHITE PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT IS CALLED NICE RACISM. HOW PROGRESSIVE WHITE PEOPLE
IS CALLED NICE RACISM. HOW PROGRESSIVE WHITE PEOPLE PERPETUATE RACIAL HARM IN
HOW PROGRESSIVE WHITE PEOPLE PERPETUATE RACIAL HARM IN THE NEW BOOK YOU WRITE QUOTE.
PERPETUATE RACIAL HARM IN THE NEW BOOK YOU WRITE QUOTE. I‘M OFTEN ASKED WHY WHITE
THE NEW BOOK YOU WRITE QUOTE. I‘M OFTEN ASKED WHY WHITE PEOPLE SHOULD LISTEN TO A
I‘M OFTEN ASKED WHY WHITE PEOPLE SHOULD LISTEN TO A WHITE PERSON ON RACISM.
PEOPLE SHOULD LISTEN TO A WHITE PERSON ON RACISM. SO LET‘S START THERE. WHAT IS
WHITE PERSON ON RACISM. SO LET‘S START THERE. WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION?
SO LET‘S START THERE. WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION? WHY SHOULD
YOUR ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION? WHY SHOULD THEY? WELL, LET ME START BY
WHY SHOULD THEY? WELL, LET ME START BY BEING VERY CLEAR THAT I
THEY? WELL, LET ME START BY BEING VERY CLEAR THAT I DO NOT BELIEVE.
BEING VERY CLEAR THAT I DO NOT BELIEVE. WHITE PEOPLE WILL EVER
DO NOT BELIEVE. WHITE PEOPLE WILL EVER UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO
WHITE PEOPLE WILL EVER UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT RACISM, IF
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT RACISM, IF WE‘RE NOT LISTENING TO BLACK
UNDERSTAND ABOUT RACISM, IF WE‘RE NOT LISTENING TO BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
WE‘RE NOT LISTENING TO BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR
PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE TO UNDERSTAND MY REALITY.
COLOR HAVE TO UNDERSTAND MY REALITY. AND UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE NOT
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND MY REALITY. AND UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE NOT THERE‘S,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE NOT THERE‘S, I DO HAVE A TAKE
THERE‘S, I DO HAVE A TAKE AN UNDERSTANDING OF IT, THAT
I DO HAVE A TAKE AN UNDERSTANDING OF IT, THAT THEY CAN‘T HAVE, AND WE
AN UNDERSTANDING OF IT, THAT THEY CAN‘T HAVE, AND WE NEED ALL PIECES OF
THEY CAN‘T HAVE, AND WE NEED ALL PIECES OF THIS PUZZLE AT THE TABLE.
NEED ALL PIECES OF THIS PUZZLE AT THE TABLE. SO EARLY ON, IN THE BOOK,
THIS PUZZLE AT THE TABLE. SO EARLY ON, IN THE BOOK, YOU RELATE A
SO EARLY ON, IN THE BOOK, YOU RELATE A SELF-CRITICAL ANECDOTE ABOUT
YOU RELATE A SELF-CRITICAL ANECDOTE ABOUT HOW YOU ONCE BEHAVED AT A
SELF-CRITICAL ANECDOTE ABOUT HOW YOU ONCE BEHAVED AT A COUPLE. I BELIEVE WE‘RE
HOW YOU ONCE BEHAVED AT A COUPLE. I BELIEVE WE‘RE AFTERWARDS. YOU‘D
COUPLE. I BELIEVE WE‘RE AFTERWARDS. YOU‘D REALISE YOU‘D SPENT MUCH OF
AFTERWARDS. YOU‘D REALISE YOU‘D SPENT MUCH OF THE EVENING TALKING ABOUT
REALISE YOU‘D SPENT MUCH OF THE EVENING TALKING ABOUT AWFUL
THE EVENING TALKING ABOUT AWFUL RACIST THINGS. SOME OTHER
AWFUL RACIST THINGS. SOME OTHER PEOPLE YOU KNEW
RACIST THINGS. SOME OTHER PEOPLE YOU KNEW HAD DONE. IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT
PEOPLE YOU KNEW HAD DONE. IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT WHAT YOU CALL SUCH
HAD DONE. IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT WHAT YOU CALL SUCH RACIALIZED MOVES OR COVERS IN
WHAT YOU CALL SUCH RACIALIZED MOVES OR COVERS IN QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
RACIALIZED MOVES OR COVERS IN QUOTE, UNQUOTE, WOKE OR PROGRESSIVE WHITE
QUOTE, UNQUOTE, WOKE OR PROGRESSIVE WHITE PEOPLE,
WOKE OR PROGRESSIVE WHITE PEOPLE, BUT THAT IS A COMMON THING.
PEOPLE, BUT THAT IS A COMMON THING. AND IS IT WITTING OR UNWITTING
BUT THAT IS A COMMON THING. AND IS IT WITTING OR UNWITTING IN YOUR
AND IS IT WITTING OR UNWITTING IN YOUR VIEW?
IN YOUR VIEW? I THINK IT‘S DEFINITELY A
VIEW? I THINK IT‘S DEFINITELY A COMMON THEME.
I THINK IT‘S DEFINITELY A COMMON THEME. I HAVE CERTAINLY GOTTEN
COMMON THEME. I HAVE CERTAINLY GOTTEN FEEDBACK ACROSS MY LIFE ABOUT
I HAVE CERTAINLY GOTTEN FEEDBACK ACROSS MY LIFE ABOUT MY ENACTMENT. I HAVE OBSERVED
FEEDBACK ACROSS MY LIFE ABOUT MY ENACTMENT. I HAVE OBSERVED COUNTLESS OTHER ENACTMENT
MY ENACTMENT. I HAVE OBSERVED COUNTLESS OTHER ENACTMENT MANY, MANY, MANY,
COUNTLESS OTHER ENACTMENT MANY, MANY, MANY, BLACK PEOPLE, AND OTHER PEOPLE
MANY, MANY, MANY, BLACK PEOPLE, AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE WRITTEN
BLACK PEOPLE, AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE WRITTEN EXHAUSTIVELY ABOUT THEIR
OF COLOR HAVE WRITTEN EXHAUSTIVELY ABOUT THEIR FRUSTRATION
EXHAUSTIVELY ABOUT THEIR FRUSTRATION WITH THIS KIND OF,
FRUSTRATION WITH THIS KIND OF, WELL-MEANING IMPLICIT KINDS OF
WITH THIS KIND OF, WELL-MEANING IMPLICIT KINDS OF RACISM. I THINK IT‘S UNWITTING
WELL-MEANING IMPLICIT KINDS OF RACISM. I THINK IT‘S UNWITTING THE IMPACT IS STILL
RACISM. I THINK IT‘S UNWITTING THE IMPACT IS STILL DEBILITATING, IT‘S STILL.
THE IMPACT IS STILL DEBILITATING, IT‘S STILL. POWERFUL IS STILL UNDER
DEBILITATING, IT‘S STILL. POWERFUL IS STILL UNDER UNDERMINES, YOU KNOW, IN SOME
POWERFUL IS STILL UNDER UNDERMINES, YOU KNOW, IN SOME WAYS, INTENTIONS ARE
UNDERMINES, YOU KNOW, IN SOME WAYS, INTENTIONS ARE LESS RELEVANT THAN THE
WAYS, INTENTIONS ARE LESS RELEVANT THAN THE IMPACT OF OUR BEHAVIOR.
LESS RELEVANT THAN THE IMPACT OF OUR BEHAVIOR. AND ROBIN IN THIS
IMPACT OF OUR BEHAVIOR. AND ROBIN IN THIS TRUMPIAN ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN,
AND ROBIN IN THIS TRUMPIAN ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN, WE SEE MORE VISIBLE
TRUMPIAN ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN, WE SEE MORE VISIBLE MALIGN RACISM AND
WE SEE MORE VISIBLE MALIGN RACISM AND ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND
MALIGN RACISM AND ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND XENOPHOBIA IN AMERICA EVEN
ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND XENOPHOBIA IN AMERICA EVEN A REACTIONARY MORAL PANIC
XENOPHOBIA IN AMERICA EVEN A REACTIONARY MORAL PANIC OVER
A REACTIONARY MORAL PANIC OVER QUOTE UNQUOTE, CRITICAL RACE
OVER QUOTE UNQUOTE, CRITICAL RACE THEORY. SOME PEOPLE MIGHT
QUOTE UNQUOTE, CRITICAL RACE THEORY. SOME PEOPLE MIGHT WONDER WHY
THEORY. SOME PEOPLE MIGHT WONDER WHY YOU‘RE FOCUSING ON
WONDER WHY YOU‘RE FOCUSING ON WELL-MEANING.
YOU‘RE FOCUSING ON WELL-MEANING. WHITE PROGRESSIVES, WHEN THOSE
WELL-MEANING. WHITE PROGRESSIVES, WHEN THOSE WHO ARE NOT
WHITE PROGRESSIVES, WHEN THOSE WHO ARE NOT WELL-MEANING. AS YOU SAY IN
WHO ARE NOT WELL-MEANING. AS YOU SAY IN THE BOOK ARE GROWING AND
WELL-MEANING. AS YOU SAY IN THE BOOK ARE GROWING AND EMBOLDENED AND I WOULD ADD
THE BOOK ARE GROWING AND EMBOLDENED AND I WOULD ADD VIOLENT. YOU GO INTO THIS IN
EMBOLDENED AND I WOULD ADD VIOLENT. YOU GO INTO THIS IN THE BOOK, CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO
VIOLENT. YOU GO INTO THIS IN THE BOOK, CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS? WHY HERE?
THE BOOK, CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS? WHY HERE? AND ROBIN IN THIS TRUMPIAN
OUR VIEWERS? WHY HERE? AND ROBIN IN THIS TRUMPIAN ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN WE SEE
AND ROBIN IN THIS TRUMPIAN ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN WE SEE MORE VISIBLE MALIGN RACISM AND
ERA. WE NOW LIVE IN WE SEE MORE VISIBLE MALIGN RACISM AND ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND
MORE VISIBLE MALIGN RACISM AND ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND AND I DO NOT WANT TO
ETHNIC NATIONALISM AND AND I DO NOT WANT TO MINIMIZE THE THE TERROR OF
AND I DO NOT WANT TO MINIMIZE THE THE TERROR OF THAT GROWING MOVEMENT AND IT
MINIMIZE THE THE TERROR OF THAT GROWING MOVEMENT AND IT IS DEFINITELY GROWING
THAT GROWING MOVEMENT AND IT IS DEFINITELY GROWING BUT IN MY 20 PLUS YEARS
IS DEFINITELY GROWING BUT IN MY 20 PLUS YEARS OF
BUT IN MY 20 PLUS YEARS OF BEING ENGAGED IN THESE
OF BEING ENGAGED IN THESE CONVERSATIONS
BEING ENGAGED IN THESE CONVERSATIONS AND RESEARCH AND OBSERVING
CONVERSATIONS AND RESEARCH AND OBSERVING AND LISTENING,
AND RESEARCH AND OBSERVING AND LISTENING, THERE‘S A THEME THAT IS
AND LISTENING, THERE‘S A THEME THAT IS EXPRESSED BY BLACK PEOPLE AND
THERE‘S A THEME THAT IS EXPRESSED BY BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THAT
EXPRESSED BY BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THAT IS THE THEME OF
OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THAT IS THE THEME OF EXHAUSTION.
IS THE THEME OF EXHAUSTION. AND THAT EXHAUSTION COMES FROM
EXHAUSTION. AND THAT EXHAUSTION COMES FROM THE MORE IMPLICIT
AND THAT EXHAUSTION COMES FROM THE MORE IMPLICIT FORMS. THE
THE MORE IMPLICIT FORMS. THE EVERYDAY FORMS BLACK PEOPLE
FORMS. THE EVERYDAY FORMS BLACK PEOPLE ARE NOT LIKELY TO BE
EVERYDAY FORMS BLACK PEOPLE ARE NOT LIKELY TO BE AROUND.
ARE NOT LIKELY TO BE AROUND. AND
AROUND. AND A WHITE NATIONALIST TO,
AND A WHITE NATIONALIST TO, THEY‘RE NOT LIKELY TO BE
A WHITE NATIONALIST TO, THEY‘RE NOT LIKELY TO BE AROUND PEOPLE WHO EXPLICITLY
THEY‘RE NOT LIKELY TO BE AROUND PEOPLE WHO EXPLICITLY EXPRESS
AROUND PEOPLE WHO EXPLICITLY EXPRESS RACIAL ANIMUS AND IN
EXPRESS RACIAL ANIMUS AND IN SOME WAYS
RACIAL ANIMUS AND IN SOME WAYS YOU KNOW, IT‘S ON THE TABLE,
SOME WAYS YOU KNOW, IT‘S ON THE TABLE, IT‘S EASIER TO PROTECT ONESELF
YOU KNOW, IT‘S ON THE TABLE, IT‘S EASIER TO PROTECT ONESELF FROM THOSE FORMS OF RACISM.
IT‘S EASIER TO PROTECT ONESELF FROM THOSE FORMS OF RACISM. THE UNCONSCIOUS FORMS ARE MUCH
FROM THOSE FORMS OF RACISM. THE UNCONSCIOUS FORMS ARE MUCH MORE CHALLENGING
THE UNCONSCIOUS FORMS ARE MUCH MORE CHALLENGING AND AGAIN,
MORE CHALLENGING AND AGAIN, THEY‘RE MUCH MORE DAILY.
AND AGAIN, THEY‘RE MUCH MORE DAILY. ANOTHER REASON IS
THEY‘RE MUCH MORE DAILY. ANOTHER REASON IS THAT I SEE THAT WHITE PEOPLE
ANOTHER REASON IS THAT I SEE THAT WHITE PEOPLE LIKE TO TAKE AS MANY EXIT
THAT I SEE THAT WHITE PEOPLE LIKE TO TAKE AS MANY EXIT POINTS AS WE CAN AND A COMMON
LIKE TO TAKE AS MANY EXIT POINTS AS WE CAN AND A COMMON ONE IS AS SOON AS YOU
POINTS AS WE CAN AND A COMMON ONE IS AS SOON AS YOU ARE CONFRONTED.
ONE IS AS SOON AS YOU ARE CONFRONTED. WITH THE REALITY OF YOUR OWN
ARE CONFRONTED. WITH THE REALITY OF YOUR OWN COMPLICITY, YOU WANT TO MOVE
WITH THE REALITY OF YOUR OWN COMPLICITY, YOU WANT TO MOVE TO THE MORE EXTREME FORMS.
COMPLICITY, YOU WANT TO MOVE TO THE MORE EXTREME FORMS. WELL WHAT ABOUT WHY
TO THE MORE EXTREME FORMS. WELL WHAT ABOUT WHY I DO NOT
WELL WHAT ABOUT WHY I DO NOT AND COULD NOT
I DO NOT AND COULD NOT CLAIM TO REPRESENT
AND COULD NOT CLAIM TO REPRESENT EVERY ASPECT OF THIS.
CLAIM TO REPRESENT EVERY ASPECT OF THIS. PROFOUNDLY COMPLEX ISSUE.
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS. PROFOUNDLY COMPLEX ISSUE. MY FOCUS IS ON THE
PROFOUNDLY COMPLEX ISSUE. MY FOCUS IS ON THE MORE IMPLICIT FORMS,
MY FOCUS IS ON THE MORE IMPLICIT FORMS, AND THAT BRINGS ME TO THE
MORE IMPLICIT FORMS, AND THAT BRINGS ME TO THE THIRD REASON.
AND THAT BRINGS ME TO THE THIRD REASON. AND THAT IS THAT I AM
THIRD REASON. AND THAT IS THAT I AM A CLASSIC WELL-MEANING
AND THAT IS THAT I AM A CLASSIC WELL-MEANING WHITE PROGRESSIVE. I KNOW,
A CLASSIC WELL-MEANING WHITE PROGRESSIVE. I KNOW, INTIMATELY BOTH THROUGH MY OWN
WHITE PROGRESSIVE. I KNOW, INTIMATELY BOTH THROUGH MY OWN ENACTMENTS THROUGH FEEDBACK.
INTIMATELY BOTH THROUGH MY OWN ENACTMENTS THROUGH FEEDBACK. BACK AND THROUGH
ENACTMENTS THROUGH FEEDBACK. BACK AND THROUGH OBSERVATION, THOSE FORMS AND
BACK AND THROUGH OBSERVATION, THOSE FORMS AND THAT IS WHAT I FOCUS ON,
OBSERVATION, THOSE FORMS AND THAT IS WHAT I FOCUS ON, THEY‘RE HARDER TO SEE
THAT IS WHAT I FOCUS ON, THEY‘RE HARDER TO SEE EASIER TO DENY AND THEREFORE
THEY‘RE HARDER TO SEE EASIER TO DENY AND THEREFORE WE NEED SOME HELP.
EASIER TO DENY AND THEREFORE WE NEED SOME HELP. HARDER TO SEE
WE NEED SOME HELP. HARDER TO SEE AN EASIER TO KNOW. I MEAN, I
HARDER TO SEE AN EASIER TO KNOW. I MEAN, I AS A BROWN, IMMIGRANT
AN EASIER TO KNOW. I MEAN, I AS A BROWN, IMMIGRANT DEFINITELY WOULD SAY
AS A BROWN, IMMIGRANT DEFINITELY WOULD SAY IT CAN BE MORE FRUSTRATING
DEFINITELY WOULD SAY IT CAN BE MORE FRUSTRATING DEALING WITH THE KIND OF
IT CAN BE MORE FRUSTRATING DEALING WITH THE KIND OF IMPLICIT
DEALING WITH THE KIND OF IMPLICIT RACISM FROM WELL-INTENTIONED
IMPLICIT RACISM FROM WELL-INTENTIONED PEOPLE WHO DON‘T REALIZE IT
RACISM FROM WELL-INTENTIONED PEOPLE WHO DON‘T REALIZE IT THAN FROM YOUR EXPLICIT. TRUMP
PEOPLE WHO DON‘T REALIZE IT THAN FROM YOUR EXPLICIT. TRUMP LIKE FIGURE WHO KIND OF I TAKE
THAN FROM YOUR EXPLICIT. TRUMP LIKE FIGURE WHO KIND OF I TAKE FOR GRANTED,
LIKE FIGURE WHO KIND OF I TAKE FOR GRANTED, THAT‘S A VERY FAIR POINT BUT
FOR GRANTED, THAT‘S A VERY FAIR POINT BUT CONSIDER THIS
THAT‘S A VERY FAIR POINT BUT CONSIDER THIS SOMETHING THAT STRIKES ME
CONSIDER THIS SOMETHING THAT STRIKES ME ABOUT THE BOOK. NICE RACISM.
SOMETHING THAT STRIKES ME ABOUT THE BOOK. NICE RACISM. IS THAT CONSERVATIVES MIGHT
ABOUT THE BOOK. NICE RACISM. IS THAT CONSERVATIVES MIGHT ACTUALLY AGREE
IS THAT CONSERVATIVES MIGHT ACTUALLY AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOUR CRITIQUE. I
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOUR CRITIQUE. I WONDER WHETHER YOU SEE
WITH A LOT OF YOUR CRITIQUE. I WONDER WHETHER YOU SEE THE WEIRD OVERLAP THAT
WONDER WHETHER YOU SEE THE WEIRD OVERLAP THAT SO THEY SEE A LOT OF WHITE
THE WEIRD OVERLAP THAT SO THEY SEE A LOT OF WHITE PROGRESSIVES, FOR EXAMPLE, OUT
SO THEY SEE A LOT OF WHITE PROGRESSIVES, FOR EXAMPLE, OUT ON THE STREETS PROTESTING AND
PROGRESSIVES, FOR EXAMPLE, OUT ON THE STREETS PROTESTING AND THEY SAY
ON THE STREETS PROTESTING AND THEY SAY THEIR VIRTUE SIGNALING,
THEY SAY THEIR VIRTUE SIGNALING, THEY‘RE TRYING TO BE WOKE,
THEIR VIRTUE SIGNALING, THEY‘RE TRYING TO BE WOKE, THEY‘RE TRYING TO OUT WOKE
THEY‘RE TRYING TO BE WOKE, THEY‘RE TRYING TO OUT WOKE EACH OTHER. THEY‘RE TRYING TO
THEY‘RE TRYING TO OUT WOKE EACH OTHER. THEY‘RE TRYING TO ROMANTICIZE MINORITY CULTURES
EACH OTHER. THEY‘RE TRYING TO ROMANTICIZE MINORITY CULTURES AND YOU KIND OF CALL THAT OUT
ROMANTICIZE MINORITY CULTURES AND YOU KIND OF CALL THAT OUT TO DON‘T YOU IN THE BOOK.
AND YOU KIND OF CALL THAT OUT TO DON‘T YOU IN THE BOOK. ISN‘T THAT A LOT OF WHAT
TO DON‘T YOU IN THE BOOK. ISN‘T THAT A LOT OF WHAT YOU‘RE CRITIQUING
ISN‘T THAT A LOT OF WHAT YOU‘RE CRITIQUING TO? YES, BUT THE
YOU‘RE CRITIQUING TO? YES, BUT THE AGENDAS ARE DIFFERENT AND WHAT
TO? YES, BUT THE AGENDAS ARE DIFFERENT AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE AGENDA
AGENDAS ARE DIFFERENT AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE AGENDA FROM THE RIGHT
I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE AGENDA FROM THE RIGHT IS TO PROTECT THE STATUS
FROM THE RIGHT IS TO PROTECT THE STATUS QUO,
IS TO PROTECT THE STATUS QUO, THE AGENDA ON THE
QUO, THE AGENDA ON THE CHALLENGE THE STATUS QUO
THE AGENDA ON THE CHALLENGE THE STATUS QUO AND SYSTEMIC
CHALLENGE THE STATUS QUO AND SYSTEMIC RACISM IS THE STATUS QUO,
AND SYSTEMIC RACISM IS THE STATUS QUO, YOU KNOW, WITHIN THAT WORK
RACISM IS THE STATUS QUO, YOU KNOW, WITHIN THAT WORK WE WANT TO GET THIS AS RIGHT
YOU KNOW, WITHIN THAT WORK WE WANT TO GET THIS AS RIGHT AS WE CAN. THAT‘S
WE WANT TO GET THIS AS RIGHT AS WE CAN. THAT‘S NOT COMPLETELY POSSIBLE,
AS WE CAN. THAT‘S NOT COMPLETELY POSSIBLE, BUT
NOT COMPLETELY POSSIBLE, BUT WE COULD DO BETTER. WE DON‘T
BUT WE COULD DO BETTER. WE DON‘T WANT TO INADVERTENTLY
WE COULD DO BETTER. WE DON‘T WANT TO INADVERTENTLY REINFORCE THE PROBLEM AS WE
WANT TO INADVERTENTLY REINFORCE THE PROBLEM AS WE SEEK TO CHALLENGE
REINFORCE THE PROBLEM AS WE SEEK TO CHALLENGE IT.
SEEK TO CHALLENGE IT. ONE OF THE
IT. ONE OF THE FIERCEST CRITICISMS OF YOUR
ONE OF THE FIERCEST CRITICISMS OF YOUR WORK AND IT‘S NOT JUST FROM
FIERCEST CRITICISMS OF YOUR WORK AND IT‘S NOT JUST FROM CONSERVATIVES, BUT SOME
WORK AND IT‘S NOT JUST FROM CONSERVATIVES, BUT SOME LIBERALS TO AND TO BE FAIR YOU
CONSERVATIVES, BUT SOME LIBERALS TO AND TO BE FAIR YOU DISCUSS IT IN THE BOOK. IS THE
LIBERALS TO AND TO BE FAIR YOU DISCUSS IT IN THE BOOK. IS THE IDEA THAT
DISCUSS IT IN THE BOOK. IS THE IDEA THAT YOU‘RE PERPETUATING A
IDEA THAT YOU‘RE PERPETUATING A QUOTE UNQUOTE RACE,
YOU‘RE PERPETUATING A QUOTE UNQUOTE RACE, ESSENTIALISM THAT IN YOUR VIEW
QUOTE UNQUOTE RACE, ESSENTIALISM THAT IN YOUR VIEW OF THE WORLD. WE CAN‘T ESCAPE
ESSENTIALISM THAT IN YOUR VIEW OF THE WORLD. WE CAN‘T ESCAPE OUR RACIAL GROUPS, WE‘RE
OF THE WORLD. WE CAN‘T ESCAPE OUR RACIAL GROUPS, WE‘RE LOCKED INTO THEM. WE ARE BLACK
OUR RACIAL GROUPS, WE‘RE LOCKED INTO THEM. WE ARE BLACK WHITE ASIAN AND THAT
LOCKED INTO THEM. WE ARE BLACK WHITE ASIAN AND THAT GROUP IDENTITY TRUMP‘S,
WHITE ASIAN AND THAT GROUP IDENTITY TRUMP‘S, WHATEVER INDIVIDUAL
GROUP IDENTITY TRUMP‘S, WHATEVER INDIVIDUAL NON RACE RELATED
WHATEVER INDIVIDUAL NON RACE RELATED CHARACTERISTICS. WE MAY HAVE
NON RACE RELATED CHARACTERISTICS. WE MAY HAVE WHICH SOME WOULD SAY IS A
CHARACTERISTICS. WE MAY HAVE WHICH SOME WOULD SAY IS A PRETTY DEPRESSING VIEW OF THE
WHICH SOME WOULD SAY IS A PRETTY DEPRESSING VIEW OF THE WORLD.
PRETTY DEPRESSING VIEW OF THE WORLD. WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK
WORLD. WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN
WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN
THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF
MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF HOPEFULNESS
SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF HOPEFULNESS THAT LED TO THE COMPLACENCY WE
HOPEFULNESS THAT LED TO THE COMPLACENCY WE SAW FOLLOWING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
THAT LED TO THE COMPLACENCY WE SAW FOLLOWING THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
SAW FOLLOWING THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT HAS LED US TO THIS MOMENT
MOVEMENT HAS LED US TO THIS MOMENT WHICH LOOKS IN A LOT OF WAYS
HAS LED US TO THIS MOMENT WHICH LOOKS IN A LOT OF WAYS PRE-CIVIL RIGHTS.
WHICH LOOKS IN A LOT OF WAYS PRE-CIVIL RIGHTS. BUT A LOT OF
PRE-CIVIL RIGHTS. BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR, EVEN NOT JUST
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR, EVEN NOT JUST GOT WHITE PEOPLE FOR A SECOND.
PEOPLE OF COLOR, EVEN NOT JUST GOT WHITE PEOPLE FOR A SECOND. A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COLOR.
GOT WHITE PEOPLE FOR A SECOND. A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COLOR. MIGHT SAY, I WANT TO BE ABLE
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COLOR. MIGHT SAY, I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
MIGHT SAY, I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE AROUND ME
TO HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE AROUND ME COLLEAGUES. STUDENTS FRIENDS,
WITH PEOPLE AROUND ME COLLEAGUES. STUDENTS FRIENDS, WITHOUT ALWAYS HAVING TO WORRY
COLLEAGUES. STUDENTS FRIENDS, WITHOUT ALWAYS HAVING TO WORRY WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK
WITHOUT ALWAYS HAVING TO WORRY WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN
WELL, I DON‘T, I DON‘T THINK THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN
THAT RACISM IS GOING TO END IN MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF
MY LIFETIME. AND I THINK, IN SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF IF YOU READ YOUR STUFF,
SOME WAYS, THE KINDS OF IF YOU READ YOUR STUFF, SOME PEOPLE COME AWAY THINKING
IF YOU READ YOUR STUFF, SOME PEOPLE COME AWAY THINKING YOU CAN ONLY SEE THE WORLD.
SOME PEOPLE COME AWAY THINKING YOU CAN ONLY SEE THE WORLD. ACCORDING TO ROBYN D‘ANGELO
YOU CAN ONLY SEE THE WORLD. ACCORDING TO ROBYN D‘ANGELO IN RACIAL GROUPS. I‘M JUST
ACCORDING TO ROBYN D‘ANGELO IN RACIAL GROUPS. I‘M JUST WONDERING. IS THAT HOW YOU SEE
IN RACIAL GROUPS. I‘M JUST WONDERING. IS THAT HOW YOU SEE OR KNOW? I THINK WE COULD
WONDERING. IS THAT HOW YOU SEE OR KNOW? I THINK WE COULD USE MUCH MORE
OR KNOW? I THINK WE COULD USE MUCH MORE AWARENESS OF THE REALITY OF
USE MUCH MORE AWARENESS OF THE REALITY OF OUR RACIAL POSITIONS. THEY
AWARENESS OF THE REALITY OF OUR RACIAL POSITIONS. THEY WORLD, THEY SHAPE OUR
OUR RACIAL POSITIONS. THEY WORLD, THEY SHAPE OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE WORLD.
WORLD, THEY SHAPE OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE WORLD. THERE‘S NOT SOME OBJECTIVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE WORLD. THERE‘S NOT SOME OBJECTIVE UNIVERSAL
THERE‘S NOT SOME OBJECTIVE UNIVERSAL HAVING.
UNIVERSAL HAVING. WE COULD LITERALLY PREDICT
HAVING. WE COULD LITERALLY PREDICT WHETHER MY MOTHER. AND I
WE COULD LITERALLY PREDICT WHETHER MY MOTHER. AND I WERE GOING TO SERVE
WHETHER MY MOTHER. AND I WERE GOING TO SERVE VIVE MY
WERE GOING TO SERVE VIVE MY BIRTH BASED ON THE FACT THAT
VIVE MY BIRTH BASED ON THE FACT THAT MY MOTHER AND I ARE WHITE
BIRTH BASED ON THE FACT THAT MY MOTHER AND I ARE WHITE SIGNIFICANT AND WE
MY MOTHER AND I ARE WHITE SIGNIFICANT AND WE DON‘T WANT TO HOLD ABSOLUTELY
SIGNIFICANT AND WE DON‘T WANT TO HOLD ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING AT ALL TIMES.
DON‘T WANT TO HOLD ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING AT ALL TIMES. BUT WE NEED TO I THINK WE NEED
EVERYTHING AT ALL TIMES. BUT WE NEED TO I THINK WE NEED TO EMBRACE IT A LITTLE MORE
BUT WE NEED TO I THINK WE NEED TO EMBRACE IT A LITTLE MORE THAN WE HAVE BEEN. YOU SPEND A
TO EMBRACE IT A LITTLE MORE THAN WE HAVE BEEN. YOU SPEND A LOT OF THE BOOK
THAN WE HAVE BEEN. YOU SPEND A LOT OF THE BOOK RELATING. SOME REALLY
LOT OF THE BOOK RELATING. SOME REALLY DISPIRITING EXPERIENCES FROM
RELATING. SOME REALLY DISPIRITING EXPERIENCES FROM RACIAL SENSITIVITY, WORKSHOPS
DISPIRITING EXPERIENCES FROM RACIAL SENSITIVITY, WORKSHOPS THAT YOU RUN OR ATTEND.
RACIAL SENSITIVITY, WORKSHOPS THAT YOU RUN OR ATTEND. I WONDER, IS THERE ANY
THAT YOU RUN OR ATTEND. I WONDER, IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE OUT THERE ABOUT THOSE
I WONDER, IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE OUT THERE ABOUT THOSE WORKSHOPS AND THE
EVIDENCE OUT THERE ABOUT THOSE WORKSHOPS AND THE VALUE THAT THEY DELIVER
WORKSHOPS AND THE VALUE THAT THEY DELIVER BECAUSE THERE IS AN ARGUMENT
VALUE THAT THEY DELIVER BECAUSE THERE IS AN ARGUMENT ON THE LEFT THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS AN ARGUMENT ON THE LEFT THAT FACILITATING, THOSE KIND OF
ON THE LEFT THAT FACILITATING, THOSE KIND OF WORKSHOPS, ESPECIALLY FOR
FACILITATING, THOSE KIND OF WORKSHOPS, ESPECIALLY FOR CORPORATIONS FOR GOVERNMENT
WORKSHOPS, ESPECIALLY FOR CORPORATIONS FOR GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS.
CORPORATIONS FOR GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS. GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE CARD,
ORGANIZATIONS. GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE CARD, ALMOST, THEY CAN SAY WELL WE
GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE CARD, ALMOST, THEY CAN SAY WELL WE PAID FOR ALL THIS STUFF. LOOK,
ALMOST, THEY CAN SAY WELL WE PAID FOR ALL THIS STUFF. LOOK, WHAT GREAT EMPLOYERS WE ARE
PAID FOR ALL THIS STUFF. LOOK, WHAT GREAT EMPLOYERS WE ARE AND I SHOULD POINT OUT FOR OUR
WHAT GREAT EMPLOYERS WE ARE AND I SHOULD POINT OUT FOR OUR VIEWERS LAST YEAR, A STUDY
AND I SHOULD POINT OUT FOR OUR VIEWERS LAST YEAR, A STUDY FOUND THAT US COMPANIES SPENT
VIEWERS LAST YEAR, A STUDY FOUND THAT US COMPANIES SPENT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
FOUND THAT US COMPANIES SPENT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS ON DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS ON DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY CONSULTANT AND
ON DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY CONSULTANT AND SOMEWHERE IN TOTAL
DIVERSITY CONSULTANT AND SOMEWHERE IN TOTAL CUMULATIVELY AROUND A BILLION,
SOMEWHERE IN TOTAL CUMULATIVELY AROUND A BILLION, HALF A BILLION A YEAR. SO I‘M
CUMULATIVELY AROUND A BILLION, HALF A BILLION A YEAR. SO I‘M WONDERING WHERE‘S THE EVIDENCE
HALF A BILLION A YEAR. SO I‘M WONDERING WHERE‘S THE EVIDENCE OR DATA THAT YOU HAVE?
WONDERING WHERE‘S THE EVIDENCE OR DATA THAT YOU HAVE? HAVE BECAUSE YOU‘RE THE EXPERT
OR DATA THAT YOU HAVE? HAVE BECAUSE YOU‘RE THE EXPERT ON THIS. I WONDER ON THOSE
HAVE BECAUSE YOU‘RE THE EXPERT ON THIS. I WONDER ON THOSE WORKSHOPS ON DIVERSITY
ON THIS. I WONDER ON THOSE WORKSHOPS ON DIVERSITY TRAINING BECAUSE
WORKSHOPS ON DIVERSITY TRAINING BECAUSE LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CYNICAL
TRAINING BECAUSE LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CYNICAL ABOUT THAT STUFF SO I‘M JUST
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CYNICAL ABOUT THAT STUFF SO I‘M JUST WONDERING HOW DO WE KNOW IT
ABOUT THAT STUFF SO I‘M JUST WONDERING HOW DO WE KNOW IT WORKS?
WONDERING HOW DO WE KNOW IT WORKS? WELL, I DON‘T THINK IT DOES
WORKS? WELL, I DON‘T THINK IT DOES WORK IF IT‘S NOT SUSTAINED
WELL, I DON‘T THINK IT DOES WORK IF IT‘S NOT SUSTAINED AND CONSISTENT. SO IF IT‘S A
WORK IF IT‘S NOT SUSTAINED AND CONSISTENT. SO IF IT‘S A IF IT‘S A
AND CONSISTENT. SO IF IT‘S A IF IT‘S A ONE-TIME THING, A CHECK, THE
IF IT‘S A ONE-TIME THING, A CHECK, THE BOX KIND OF APPROACH, IT‘S
ONE-TIME THING, A CHECK, THE BOX KIND OF APPROACH, IT‘S NOT GOING TO
BOX KIND OF APPROACH, IT‘S NOT GOING TO KEEP YOU KNOW, KEEP GOING.
NOT GOING TO KEEP YOU KNOW, KEEP GOING. IT HAS TO BE SUSTAINED
KEEP YOU KNOW, KEEP GOING. IT HAS TO BE SUSTAINED AS QUESTION WHY WE THINK THERE
IT HAS TO BE SUSTAINED AS QUESTION WHY WE THINK THERE WOULD BE A SIMPLE ANSWER
AS QUESTION WHY WE THINK THERE WOULD BE A SIMPLE ANSWER OR SOLUTION. WE COULD TAKE
WOULD BE A SIMPLE ANSWER OR SOLUTION. WE COULD TAKE THIS
OR SOLUTION. WE COULD TAKE THIS WORKSHOP OR SHOULD BE ABLE TO
THIS WORKSHOP OR SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS WORKSHOP AND FIGURE
WORKSHOP OR SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS WORKSHOP AND FIGURE OUT
MAKE THIS WORKSHOP AND FIGURE OUT SOMETHING AS
OUT SOMETHING AS PARENTALLY
SOMETHING AS PARENTALLY COMPLEX AND DEEP
PARENTALLY COMPLEX AND DEEP DEEP AND ENDURING.
COMPLEX AND DEEP DEEP AND ENDURING. AS RACISM. IT
DEEP AND ENDURING. AS RACISM. IT IS HIGHLY ADAPTIVE IT
AS RACISM. IT IS HIGHLY ADAPTIVE IT CHALLENGES AND IT KEEPS ON
IS HIGHLY ADAPTIVE IT CHALLENGES AND IT KEEPS ON RIGHT NOW. LOOK AT
CHALLENGES AND IT KEEPS ON RIGHT NOW. LOOK AT VOTER SUPPRESSION.
RIGHT NOW. LOOK AT VOTER SUPPRESSION. YES. LOOK AT
VOTER SUPPRESSION. YES. LOOK AT THE ACTUAL LAWS. ENACTED THAT
YES. LOOK AT THE ACTUAL LAWS. ENACTED THAT SAY YOU CAN‘T ACKNOWLEDGE
THE ACTUAL LAWS. ENACTED THAT SAY YOU CAN‘T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT RACISM
SAY YOU CAN‘T ACKNOWLEDGE THAT RACISM EXISTS OR LAWS THAT SAY YOU
THAT RACISM EXISTS OR LAWS THAT SAY YOU CAN‘T TEACH THE HISTORY OF
EXISTS OR LAWS THAT SAY YOU CAN‘T TEACH THE HISTORY OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
CAN‘T TEACH THE HISTORY OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. THIS IT‘S A IT‘S A MOVING
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. THIS IT‘S A IT‘S A MOVING TARGET IN SO MANY WAYS AND SO
THIS IT‘S A IT‘S A MOVING TARGET IN SO MANY WAYS AND SO ANYTIME WE THINK
TARGET IN SO MANY WAYS AND SO ANYTIME WE THINK IT‘S ALL IT‘S GOING TO ADDRESS
ANYTIME WE THINK IT‘S ALL IT‘S GOING TO ADDRESS IN TROUBLE.
IT‘S ALL IT‘S GOING TO ADDRESS IN TROUBLE. AND I AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOUR
IN TROUBLE. AND I AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOUR WHERE YOU‘RE COMING FROM AND
AND I AGREE WITH A LOT OF YOUR WHERE YOU‘RE COMING FROM AND AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT
WHERE YOU‘RE COMING FROM AND AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT YOU‘RE SAYING,
AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT YOU‘RE SAYING, BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I HAVE
YOU‘RE SAYING, BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I HAVE ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I HAVE ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN A SEMINAR OR WORKSHOP
ASKED TO PARTICIPATE IN A SEMINAR OR WORKSHOP AT WORK AND ONE
SEMINAR OR WORKSHOP AT WORK AND ONE RACISM AND WAS SEPARATED OUT
AT WORK AND ONE RACISM AND WAS SEPARATED OUT INTO A ROOM WITH ONLY OTHER
RACISM AND WAS SEPARATED OUT INTO A ROOM WITH ONLY OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHILE WHITE
INTO A ROOM WITH ONLY OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHILE WHITE PEOPLE WENT INTO ANOTHER ROOM,
PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHILE WHITE PEOPLE WENT INTO ANOTHER ROOM, I WOULD FIND IT KIND OF
PEOPLE WENT INTO ANOTHER ROOM, I WOULD FIND IT KIND OF UNCOMFORTABLE AND I KNOW AGAIN
I WOULD FIND IT KIND OF UNCOMFORTABLE AND I KNOW AGAIN YOU DISCUSS IN THE BOOK THAT
UNCOMFORTABLE AND I KNOW AGAIN YOU DISCUSS IN THE BOOK THAT THERE‘S THIS KIND OF WHITE
YOU DISCUSS IN THE BOOK THAT THERE‘S THIS KIND OF WHITE PANIC.
THERE‘S THIS KIND OF WHITE PANIC. I THINK YOU CALL IT WHITE
PANIC. I THINK YOU CALL IT WHITE PEOPLE PANIC WHEN THEY‘RE
I THINK YOU CALL IT WHITE PEOPLE PANIC WHEN THEY‘RE ASKED TO SEPARATE OUT AND TALK
PEOPLE PANIC WHEN THEY‘RE ASKED TO SEPARATE OUT AND TALK AMONGST THEMSELVES BUT IN
ASKED TO SEPARATE OUT AND TALK AMONGST THEMSELVES BUT IN AND ALSO A REAL
AMONGST THEMSELVES BUT IN AND ALSO A REAL FOR THE SAKE OF
AND ALSO A REAL FOR THE SAKE OF WELL-INTENTIONED,
FOR THE SAKE OF WELL-INTENTIONED, WELL-INTENTIONED GOAL OF
WELL-INTENTIONED, WELL-INTENTIONED GOAL OF REDUCING RACISM, WE MIGHT BE
WELL-INTENTIONED GOAL OF REDUCING RACISM, WE MIGHT BE BRINGING BACK IN RACIAL
REDUCING RACISM, WE MIGHT BE BRINGING BACK IN RACIAL SEGREGATION BY THE BACK
BRINGING BACK IN RACIAL SEGREGATION BY THE BACK DOOR.
SEGREGATION BY THE BACK DOOR. WELL, WHAT YOU‘RE TALKING
DOOR. WELL, WHAT YOU‘RE TALKING ABOUT IS IS A TECHNIQUE
WELL, WHAT YOU‘RE TALKING ABOUT IS IS A TECHNIQUE CALLED AFFINITY GROUPS. IT‘S
ABOUT IS IS A TECHNIQUE CALLED AFFINITY GROUPS. IT‘S ADVANCED
CALLED AFFINITY GROUPS. IT‘S ADVANCED IN KIND OF A MAINSTREAM
ADVANCED IN KIND OF A MAINSTREAM DIVERSITY TRAINING, BUT YOU
IN KIND OF A MAINSTREAM DIVERSITY TRAINING, BUT YOU KNOW, WE WE ARE POSITIONED
DIVERSITY TRAINING, BUT YOU KNOW, WE WE ARE POSITIONED CONSTRUCT. WE ARE SOCIALIZED
KNOW, WE WE ARE POSITIONED CONSTRUCT. WE ARE SOCIALIZED DIFFERENTLY
CONSTRUCT. WE ARE SOCIALIZED DIFFERENTLY AS A WHITE PERSON. I HAVE
DIFFERENTLY AS A WHITE PERSON. I HAVE RECEIVED ACROSS MY LIFE AND
AS A WHITE PERSON. I HAVE RECEIVED ACROSS MY LIFE AND INTERNALISED THE MESSAGE
RECEIVED ACROSS MY LIFE AND INTERNALISED THE MESSAGE OF
INTERNALISED THE MESSAGE OF SUPERIORITY.
OF SUPERIORITY. AND THAT‘S A VERY DIFFERENT
SUPERIORITY. AND THAT‘S A VERY DIFFERENT MESSAGE THAN PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND THAT‘S A VERY DIFFERENT MESSAGE THAN PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE GIVEN. AND SO, THERE ARE
MESSAGE THAN PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE GIVEN. AND SO, THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THIS WORK THAT WE
ARE GIVEN. AND SO, THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THIS WORK THAT WE DO NEED TO DO
ASPECTS OF THIS WORK THAT WE DO NEED TO DO SEPARATELY AMONG OURSELVES
DO NEED TO DO SEPARATELY AMONG OURSELVES AMONG OTHER PEOPLE WHO SHARE
SEPARATELY AMONG OURSELVES AMONG OTHER PEOPLE WHO SHARE OUR IDENTITIES AND WITHOUT THE
AMONG OTHER PEOPLE WHO SHARE OUR IDENTITIES AND WITHOUT THE MISTAKES OR
OUR IDENTITIES AND WITHOUT THE MISTAKES OR HURTING OTHER PEOPLE,
MISTAKES OR HURTING OTHER PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THERE IS NOT GOING
HURTING OTHER PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE ANYTHING ON A
YOU KNOW, THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE ANYTHING ON A TOPIC.
TO BE ANYTHING ON A TOPIC. WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE AS DEEP
TOPIC. WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE AS DEEP IN BOTH CHALLENGING AND
WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE AS DEEP IN BOTH CHALLENGING AND PROTECTING AS THE ISSUE OF